épilogue judiciaire de la sphère de la
profanation de cimetière juif de
carpentras les quatre skinheads ont été
condamnés à des peines de 20 à 24 mois
de prison ferme
reportage valérie ermite herry giorgio
puis que quelques minutes et madeleine
germain connaîtra les pilotes judiciaire
de la profanation de la tombe de son
mari à un mois près c'était il ya sept
ans ça finisse jeunes un peu plus et
fatigué j'en ai assez
et je voudrais quitter carpentras là où
negro est ce que ces deux ans de prison
après que ce qu'ils ont fait je
comprends je comprends rien la preuve
est la justice française
est ce que vous auriez préféré je ne
sais pas si elle ne sait plus très bien
quoi penser madeleine germond à la fois
déçu tout en ne regrettant pas le pardon
qu'elle leur a accordé au même moment au
palais de justice de marseille le
jugement vient de tomber deux ans le
maximum pour faire briller la au negro
les plus déterminés ce qui selon le
tribunal semble encore inspiré par les
relents de leur pensée 20 mois pour
garnier nouveau ceux qui ont demandé
pardon qu'on a châtié
avec cette peine de deux ans
d'emprisonnement les mecs qui ont réagi
il espère que ce procès aura un
enseignement pour les têtes qui pense
c'est à dire ceux qui véhiculent une
idéologie pareil à carpentras cette fois
le maire respire la ville pourra
peut-être enfin tourner la page
l'image de leur parle trahi sa ligne il
faut bien le dire et on était un point
noir sur la carte
donc j'espère qu'aujourd'hui les gens
les français verront deuil neufs donnant
un nouveau mot proville madeleine elle a
pardonné mais n'a rien oublié
elle voudrait maintenant quitté la ville
mais le pourra t'elle vraiment